là et puis à l'approche du sommet annuel
de l'OTAN à Vilnius le secrétaire
général de l'OTAN Yann toltenberg a
donné tout à l'heure une conférence de
presse dans laquelle il donne donc un
avant-goût des grands sujets qui seront
au cœur de ce sommeil on en parle
justement avec Bruno Darroux bonjour
Bruno lalliance Atlantique qui va à
l'occasion de se sommet de Vilnius
exposé disons ces nouvelles ambitions
pour l'avenir de l'organisation mais oui
une organisation qui porte plutôt bien
merci Vladimir Poutine pourrait presque
dire yens Stoltenberg parce que on se
souvient que ça avait été un des
arguments avancé par le président russe
pour lancer son offensive contre
l'Ukraine en février 2022 c'était de
dire que l'OTAN menait une politique
impérialiste et ne cesser de s'étendre
qu'il fallait donner un coup d'arrêt à
cette ambition et bien c'est un peu tout
le contraire qui se passe non seulement
on le sait la Russie est embourbé dans
cette guerre en Ukraine mais du coup
cette impérialisme russe pour le coup a
permis à deux nouveaux pays de postuler
à l'OTAN la Finlande c'est fait la Suède
pas tout à fait encore on va y revenir
alors évidemment il y a le soltenberg il
a des grandes des grandes ambitions pour
cette organisation il a parlé d'un d'un
plan d'action de production qui doit
augmenter c'est-à-dire en gros il faut
que l'OTAN produise davantage d'armes et
puis aussi renforcer ce qu'il appelle
l'interopérabilité c'est-à-dire en gros
la coopération entre les différents
alliés sur le terrain notamment
évidemment sur le front est évidemment
ashraine ça veut dire qu'il faut
dépenser plus d'argent investir
davantage
les hyène se soltenberg est revenu sur
cet objectif que chaque allié chaque
membre des 31 pour le moment membre de
l'OTAN arrive à dépenser un minimum
désormais pour rien saltenberg un
minimum de 2% du PIB il a rappelé que en
2014 il n'y avait que trois alliés qui
avaient atteint cet objectif on en est
aujourd'hui il y a 11 vous voyez quand
même qu'il en manque un certain nombre
donc ça ce sera discuté à Vilnius et
puis plus largement sur la mission de
l'OTAN elle n'est pas simplement comme
c'était historiquement le cas
géographiquement réservé aux continents
européens en quelque sorte mais dit le
secrétaire général de l'OTAN à Vilnius
on parlera aussi des problèmes de
sécurité mondiale c'est pour ça que
seront invités des pays comme le Japon
la Corée du Sud ou l'Australie notamment
car les enjeux de sécurité mondiale sont
très importants en termes de
cyberattaque de sécurité maritime et de
nouvelles technologies enfin il s'est
félicité d'une coopération renforcée et
de meilleure qualité entre l'OTAN et
l'Union européenne et l'un des
principaux enjeux je le disais c'est le
feu vert ou pas pour l'adhésion de la
Suède et puis une perspective d'adhésion
renouvelée également pour pour le crâne
et oui alors pour la Suède c'est pas
gagné la Finlande elle sera donc le
nouveau membre à vilni ça c'est sûr la
Suède ça va être le suspense jusqu'à la
fin en fait puisqu'il y aura une réunion
le 10 juillet la veille du début du
sommet pour essayer
avec la Turquie de convaincre la Turquie
voilà de lever son opposition mais pour
le moment il y a eu déjà des réunions
intermédiaires hier notamment je crois
pour le moment Ankara reste sur ses
positions la Suède ne fait pas assez
pour lutter contre ce que Ankara appelle
le terrorisme kurde le fait d'héberger
des militants kurde donc on verra bien
ça c'est un point d'interrogation et qui
sera réglé au tout dernier moment et
puis bien sûr il y a l'Ukraine on sait
que zenenski le président
ukrainien est en tournée pour à la fois
demander davantage d'armes et il veut
obtenir à ce sommet de Vilnius une
déclaration assez claire disons que
l'Ukraine intégrera le temps dès que la
guerre sera finie et ça c'est tout ce
qui va être négocié à Vénus parce
qu'aujourd'hui yens soltenberg a dit
bien sûr l'Ukraine a vocation à
rejoindre l'OTAN un jour mais il n'a pas
voulu évidemment s'avancer davantage
merci